yeah we're picking up reports from all
over the city it's crazy up there
crazier than normal you mean yo Mikey
that beats almost warmed up a what come
on
and like we got all stinking night
patients dude wise men say you can't
rush perfection it's a microwave bleep
everyone it's Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Justin Clark for
his review of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles mutants in Manhattan without a
doubt the new Ninja Turtles game is a
disappointment one multiplied several
times over not just by its pedigree but
by the fact that the right ingredients
for a good game are present bringing the
turtles to life using the same
attractive cel-shaded style as this
simple but satisfying transformers
devastation is the right choice sticking
to the beat'em up genre that has served
the Turtles so well since 1989 is
another good choice the game also
manages to get the tone right with
cutscenes delivering enjoyable slices of
the turtles as wisecracking cartoon
crime fighters trying to figure out
shredder and krang's latest evil plan
and yet the second the controller is in
your hands all the surface details that
the game gets right quickly fall away
the tutorial in the first stage
introduced a plethora of new game
mechanics green spheres can be collected
to gain items and bonuses the parry
system depending on when your turtle
dodges can have three different effects
on an enemy there's a takedown mechanic
where unaware enemies can be destroyed
and one hit if you can stealth close
enough enjutsu special attacks done by
holding a trigger button and pressing
one of the face buttons can be swapped
around in menus and unlocked using XP
during battle
items and stat boosts can also be
purchased from splinter in the turtles
lair whenever you find an open manhole
all of this creates the illusion of an
action RPG with depth but it's a farce
aside from the ninjutsu attacks there
are very few battles in this game that
cannot be solved by spamming basic light
and heavy attacks the rest however are
needless distractions items are all over
the place but only the pizzas which
restore health are of any service in a
major fight ranged weapons don't chip
away nearly as much help as they should
and are awkward to pull out in battle
power boosts offer the same minimal
effect the core of the game is certainly
easy enough to understand with two
attacks to jump in and dodge but hits
have no heft and even the simplest
enemies in the first level taken an
ordinate long
to kill ninjutsu attacks for all their
flash and flair don't always knock an
enemy down only knocking off a small
portion of their health bar the biggest
detriment to combat though is the sheer
inability to tell what exactly is
happening in any of it four turtles
fighting in the same area at the same
time turns the battlefield into a
sparkly cartoon dust cloud of mayhem if
there's a moment when the game actually
starts to come together it's during boss
fights with only one giant enemy to
focus on whose attacks are flashing and
brutal but easy to read the relative
chaos ADIZ encounters can at least make
sense action takes out an arcade
equality that momentarily conjures
memories of great Turtles games from the
past
there are also secret bosses who can
show up when replaying a level and make
a sincere plea for replay value just to
see what twists the game might throw
your way the second time around
however despite its relatively short
playtime you can see Manhattan isn't a
boss rush sort of game there's a lot of
running around see me looking sewers
running across poorly designed rooftops
and performing random disjointed and
boring fetch quests for a woefully
underutilized April O'Neil before it's
time for a big fight and once again the
key problem leaves its head fights are
just wild button mashing affairs where
the fruits of your labors leave you at
effect rather than looking forward to
what Michelangelo could do to the next
guy or what Donatello might pull off
this time
for the first time since the infamous
dam level in the original Turtles game
on the NES god it sucks to be a
turquoise man say
man I'm totally a wise man